hey everybody welcome to the first
official episode of the wednesday
checkup i have my puppy bear oh
is he still in the shot when he's like
this i have to tell you a crazy story of
something that happened to us just a few
days ago at the end of this video i'm
going to be giving you tips on how to
protect yourself in case a dog attacks
you and how to break up a dog fight if
your dog gets into a fight with another
all right let me get to this story bear
will come back a little bit later and
say bye to you guys a few days ago i was
filming for the youtube channel surprise
i'm not going to tell you the video it's
going to be out later this month and i
decided to take bear downstairs to the
dog park bear is there twice a day at
least so he knows all the other dogs he
plays really well especially with the
little uh chihuahuas and frenchies
there's even one that looks like uh a
wookie
he loves it he's in heaven they are in
heaven all the owners know bear i get to
the dog park i see a young lady come in
with a golden retriever first little
suspicious sign is her golden retriever
pulled her in to the dog park i i was
like all right she doesn't have great
control of her dog and i watch these
things i want to know right away if
there's a problem dog coming in so i
have to hold there make sure that he
doesn't get hurt it still looked
friendly tail was wagging and it's a
golden retriever at the end of the day
you know and right away she tells me uh
that her dog doesn't really like big
dogs and is kind of afraid of them bear
said hi to that dog and it gave him like
a little pause and bear just continued
along his merry way playing with the
other ducks about five minutes go by all
of a sudden i see that bear is standing
right next to the golden side by side
but they're showing all the signs of
aggression frozen mouths closed
slobbering tails up very rigid pose the
other dog owner comes over and sort of
shoves her dog away from bear and that
triggers the golden snarling and the
golden just dives at bear i initially
was like okay a dog fight i i've seen
these happen i know how to break this up
no worries as soon as i run up to
control the situation she grabs her her
dog's collar it was a big golden
retriever it was probably like 95 pounds
she ends up falling with the golden
retriever because there's a little mound
in the park and she falls onto the
concrete holding the gold and the lady
starts screaming her golden is locked on
her forearm her own golden retriever
she's screaming it's me it's me crying
for help two people from the street
jumped the fence of the dog park start
punching her dog in the face to get it
to let go because it's i mean this is a
big dog and it's completely like
smashing her forearm finally let's go
but as soon as it lets go it gets angry
and jumps on her again luckily all the
people that were there they were able to
control it with the collar pulling on
its legs this gnat pulled up her uh
sweater and showed me her wounds and she
had deep puncture wounds at least three
deep puncture wounds what it seemed like
and some smaller cuts as well and
bleeding from the nose and the head
she's like well i don't need to go to
the hospital for this and i'm like
you really need to see a doctor you
don't know if you have an infection you
don't know if you're gonna continue
bleeding you need probably stitches and
antibiotics my adrenaline at that point
was just through the roof i've seen dogs
get into fights many times it just
happens you know dogs are animals you
have to correct them sometimes and i've
even seen dogs accidentally by humans
when humans would put their hands in the
middle of a dog fight but i've never
seen a dog attack another dog who first
of all wasn't being violent and then
when separated go after a human but not
just any human its own human if that dog
went for her neck and bit through her
jugular vein or carotid artery she could
have bled out and died here's what to do
if your dog gets into a dog fight first
please whatever you do don't stick your
hands fingers arms legs in between two
dogs that are fighting you're just
asking to get bit if you have two dogs
that know each other and they're sort of
fighting at home a very simple thing to
do is throw a blanket over them that
would usually make them disperse if
you're in a situation where you want to
say no and be firm and yell at the dog i
wouldn't really recommend that loud
voices can actually get the dogs even
angrier and make them want to go at each
other more think about like a boxer
inside a boxing ring they don't hear
people chanting they're just in the zone
but on the off chance if you have like
something like an air horn that makes a
really loud high pitch noise it can be
loud enough to disperse the fight now
the most effective way to separate two
dogs are that are fighting requires two
people one on either side behind the
dogs you want to pick up the hind legs
and do something known as a wheelbarrow
technique as soon as you lift up the
hind legs generally the dogs will want
to let go because they don't know what's
going on but as soon as you lift up the
dogs try and move in a circular fashion
as you move in the circular fashion it
will give the dog something to do but be
careful because the dog will try and
kick its legs out you really need to get
a solid grip and you don't want to get
bitten now what if the dog attacks you
first of all do not run whatever you do
dogs are very fast and they have a
natural prey drive that makes them want
to chase stand up tall stand sideways
and not make eye contact so it's not
confrontational you do still want to
keep an eye on the dog without making
eye contact next in a firm voice you
want to tell the dog no you just have to
say it very passionately confident that
you're willing to stand your own ground
at the same time you want to make fists
and it's not because i want you to get
ready to fight the dog but it's because
the first things to get bitten and
bitten off are fingers if you keep them
in fists you're less likely to lose a
finger if the dog doesn't care that you
try to stand non-confrontationally not
make eye contact and gave it a command
and it still attacks you at this point
you have to do what you have to do punch
the dog in the nose hit it in its throat
those are its two most sensitive areas
if you can kick it in the rib cage
that's another thing you can do and if
you're completely losing the fight make
sure to roll up and protect your
sensitive areas your throat and face if
you're able to wrestle with the dog and
get on top of it and pin it know that
the only way a dog can really hurt you
is with its mouth by getting on top of
the dog and pinning it down you can
really neutralize the threat of the dog
biting you while you're fighting off
this dog you're also yelling for help in
hopes that other people hear you and
come to your aid if the dog runs away or
you're able to get away call for help
right away and you need to go see a
doctor you need to make sure your
vaccinations are up to date it was a
rabid dog you may need a series of
injections you'll probably need
antibiotics you may need sutures to stop
the bleeding get help as soon as
possible the last thing you want to do
is faint because of blood loss and not
have anybody help you once your health
is taken care of make sure you report
the dog bite to the proper authorities
the last thing you want is for that dog
to bite another person or animal i'm not
a animal behavior specialist i do have a
lot of experience in raising dogs and
understanding when they're about to get
angry or do something wrong but even
here i was shook i needed to go and look
up some information about what to do and
refresh my memory so i decided to make
this video for you guys whether or not
you own a dog i think this is useful
information if you have any questions
about this story if you have any
comments about the story jump in the
comment section down below if you want
more videos with my little bear pup
please let me know because i'm always
down to film with bear and he loves
being on camera and most importantly as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]
you